[Música]
bien
el agua ha fascinado al ser humano
durante toda su historia
y una de las facetas del agua que nos ha
llamado la atención es precisamente como
el agua es un reflejo de las cosas y
esto coincidentemente
simboliza el aspecto actual del agua es
la dualidad del agua y cuando hablamos
de la dualidad del agua nos referimos a
qué
los fenómenos naturales tienen varias
versiones en sí mismas que son opuestas
pero que conviven dentro de sí
hace 500 años leonardo da vinci nos
hablaba de la dualidad del agua
precisamente indicándonos que el agua
podía ser amarga podía ser dulce podía
ser gruesa podía ser delgada
pero más que todo nos decía que la vida
que el agua nos da vida y nos da salud
pero también nos trae pestilencia y
muerte
pero el concepto de la dualidad del agua
es mucho más antiguo
por más de 3000 años en la región de
guatemala en mesoamérica los pueblos
originarios ya concebían el agua de ese
punto de la dualidad a tal grado que las
deidades acuáticas
tenían estos dos aspectos el dios de la
lluvia por ejemplo por un lado nos
brindaba la lluvia la fertilidad de la
tierra pero por otro lado era también la
deidad del trueno y la tormenta que trae
la destrucción
en esta escena del códice dresde podemos
ver a la diosa ixchel que también vierte
el agua de lluvia en un cántaro pero por
encima de ella también está esta
serpiente celestial de la cual pues cae
este chorro de agua que en este caso es
una inundación que causa una de las
destrucciones de las primeras creaciones
así que
podemos decir
en la antigüedad en realidad se
imaginaban estas deidades y ahora
estamos en el mundo moderno pero que tan
diferentes en realidad somos en cuanto a
nuestra concepción del agua cuando
aprendemos un chorro que exactamente
sabe de dónde viene esa agua
oa donde bajó así que cuando abrimos el
chorro es casi que como el chorro que
cae la serpiente como por arte de magia
porque no estamos conscientes de ese
ciclo del agua que nosotros tenemos y la
tecnología nos brinda esa magia de tener
agua en un chorro
así que lo único que sí no sabemos a
dónde va oa dónde viene el agua lo que
sí sabemos es que tenemos que pasar por
esa agua ya sean una empresa o es el
gobierno que no la brinda y eso sí es un
factor común en la historia de la
humanidad
porque el ser humano ha elegido donde
vivir dependiendo de las fuentes de agua
controlando el agua las mayores
civilizaciones en la historia de la
humanidad han transformado regiones
incluso hasta desérticas en grandes
ciudades aquí vemos por ejemplo el río
tigris que atraviesa la ciudad de bagdad
y fue el corazón de todas las
civilizaciones en mesopotamia o también
el río tíber fue de donde surge el
imperio romano o el río más grande del
mundo el río amarillo que ha sido el
fundamento del desarrollo de la
civilización de china por más de ocho
mil años o porque no el eje central de
la economía eeuu el río mississippi
pero si bien el manejo de agua ha sido
la clave para el surgimiento de las
civilizaciones la falta de agua también
en este aspecto dual
puede causar el abandono y la
destrucción del ser humano
así que
cómo podemos nosotros visualizar ese
futuro sin agua
por supuesto que tenemos todo
lo que podemos saber de un análisis muy
científico del agua y podemos hacer
muchas predicciones pero el día de hoy
les digo que una película de hollywood
tal vez nos puede dar la mejor lección y
la saga de mad max quienes la han visto
es precisamente la que nos da una
lección muy importante y es que quien
tiene el agua tiene el poder tal vez en
un futuro no muy lejano que encontró el
agua va a controlar todo el mundo
pero dejemos a un lado la ciencia
ficción y vemos que nos dice la
arqueología
el caso del desierto del sahara hace
ocho mil quinientos años era una era una
región verde como la sabana africana
pero por procesos naturales de cambio
climático durante cinco mil años se
convierte en un área desértica
y los puntos rojos indican ahí las
poblaciones y ven como cuando se vuelve
una región seca la gente por supuesto se
va a vivir a lo largo del río nilo
y precisamente quienes lograron
controlar las inundaciones de río nilo
fueron quienes entonces tomaron el
control de la sociedad y los faraones
egipcios con ese poder lograron entonces
transformar ese desierto y crear una de
las civilizaciones más impresionantes
del mundo así que esa imagen nos muestra
esa dualidad de como el agua nos trae
vida pero también el manejo tecnológico
del agua es que nos da esa base
pero no ya más cerca de nuestro
territorio
en el petén se transformó la selva
tropical también como la cuna de una de
las civilizaciones más grandes que ha
visto el mundo y en este caso la
tecnología transformó la selva
utilizando estas lagunas que se llenan
durante la época de lluvia y entonces
permitía tener esas grandes reservas
para una gran población que incluso
llegó a superar los 7 millones de
habitantes
los gobernantes de las ciudades mayas
entonces contaban con un equipo de
ingenieros hidráulicos que desarrollaron
la tecnología y el conocimiento para
poder almacenar el agua suficiente para
mantener ciudades de más de 100 mil
habitantes a lo largo de todo el año y
fue un sistema tan eficiente que hizo
que esta situación lograra ser
sostenible por más de un milenio
si nos vamos ya más cerca del caso de la
situación de la ciudad de guatemala
también acá en tiempos antiguos existía
la ciudad de caminar julio la cual como
pueden imaginarse también se diseñó
alrededor del recurso hidráulico del
lago miraflores ahora abajo de lo que es
la mayor área comercial de la ciudad de
guatemala y en la gomina flores fue
aprovechado mediante un sistema también
de canales hidráulicos muy sofisticados
que incluso llegaron a tener una comuna
un sistema de compuertas similar al que
se usa hoy en día en el canal de panamá
pero el símbolo del avance hidráulico en
kaminal juyú es el acueducto conocido
como el montículo de la culebra el cual
abastecía también al valle de guatemala
en tiempos prehispánicos fue construido
hace 2500 años y en el siglo 19 fue
aprovechado por los ingenieros españoles
y se construyó entonces un acueducto de
ladrillo sobre el antiguo acueducto
de kaminal juyú este acueducto llevaba
agua desde esa cantata santa catarina
pinula y tenía una longitud de más de 5
kilómetros lo que lo hizo una de las
obras hidráulicas más grandes de toda
mesoamérica
pero
qué bien estas ciudades fueron
planificadas de una manera muy eficiente
fueron muy exitosas pero de nuevo
viendo este aspecto de la calidad del
agua son ciudades que fueron también
vulnerables a los efectos destructivos
del agua y aquí es donde podemos
analizar como cada sociedad tiene una
capacidad de respuesta ante el efecto
destructivo del agua recientemente hemos
visto como el agua puede causar mucho
daño incluso hasta las ciudades más
modernas pero lo importante acá es la
capacidad respuesta de la sociedad que
permite que una ciudad se recupere en un
tiempo corto y la clave es que los
gobiernos deben organizar a la población
y deben también aprovechar la tecnología
con la que se cuenta para poder entonces
controlar este manejo de agua sin
embargo cuando se combina una crisis
social política con una crisis ambiental
entonces es donde los efectos de una
catástrofe hidráulica pueden ser a una
escala mucho mayor
en el caso de mesoamérica no fue el
exceso de agua sino fue la falta de agua
lo que le representó un reto a estas
antiguas ciudades porque se sostenían
más que todo de la agricultura y por lo
tanto el agua era muy muy importante
algunos registros históricos nos nos
indican con el caso de 1.447 que se
dieron sequías incluso hasta de 8 años
pero esto no necesariamente significó el
abandono de las ciudades y los
territorios esta sequía que sucede en
méxico en tenochtitlán no afectó el
poderío del imperio azteca o sea ellos
pudieron tener una capacidad de
respuesta pero cuando nos vamos a
analizar el caso de las ciudades de
petén vemos que la vulnerabilidad de
estas ciudades era mucho mayor en primer
lugar porque la captación de agua era
centralizada dependía de ese
aparato sofisticado de recolección y
distribución de agua aunque quiero decir
que la ventaja de estos sistemas es que
eran sistemas abiertos y visibles de la
gente se da cuenta cuando el nivel de
agua iba bajando hoy en día como el agua
es subterránea la verdad es que no nos
hemos dado cuenta que estamos ya en
camino a una crisis
la arqueología nos ha demostrado que a
finales del siglo octavo las ciudades
empiezan a sufrir una crisis social y
política la cual fue seguida de una
crisis ambiental de aproximadamente 100
años entre los años 830 y 930 y fue la
combinación de esos dos factores lo que
hizo que más de tres o cuatro millones
de personas abandonaran su territorio y
pues es lo que se conoce pues como el
gran colapso maya del periodo clásico
ahora bien este no fue el final de esa
civilización hubieron muchas familias
que lograron sobrevivir en el momento de
que abandonan el territorio de la selva
tropical
la arqueología también nos indica que
mucha gente emigró hacia el norte
es difícil imaginar que migran a la
región donde llueve menos en esta área
pero qué sucede está estas sociedades
del norte estaban mejor preparadas a
vivir con la escasez de agua y lo más
importante las ciudades no eran tan
grandes y eran regidas por un sistema
descentralizado qué quiere decir que
cada familia recolectaba su propia agua
y no dependían de un aparato estatal
para obtener el agua que ellos
necesitaban así que aquí es donde
empezamos a aprender las lecciones
básicas y claves en cuanto a cómo una
sociedad responde ante una crisis de
agua
por lo tanto si regresamos al concepto
de la dualidad del agua también tenemos
que tomar en cuenta que el agua va a
traer vida o va a traer muerte
dependiendo también de como nosotros
respondamos a través de la tecnología
y aquí la pregunta es la tecnología
actual nos está preparando para la
escasez o nos está volviendo más
vulnerables yo sí les digo cuando falta
el agua no creo que los teléfonos
inteligentes de las tarjetas de crédito
nos vayan a solucionar el problema acá
creo que la decisión es si la tecnología
nos está dando las respuestas que
nosotros necesitamos y aquí ya hemos
aprendido de sociedades pasadas como los
mayas que la clave es el almacenamiento
de agua y la autosostenibilidad
a tal grado que ya tenemos muchas ideas
tal vez no implementadas en guatemala
pero muchos países sabemos que hay gente
que está desarrollando métodos para que
cada familia pueda almacenar su propia
agua y no depender de que una empresa o
un gobierno me resuelve el problema a mí
así que está en nuestras manos
y el tomar esas decisiones o simplemente
seguir pensando que el agua va a salir
de nuestros chorros como por arte de
magia muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]